[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires et bien cette
crise sanitaire a changé bien de nos
comportements notamment avec vous allez
voir dans ce reportage une nouvelle
façon de faire nos courses en effet une
arche de désinfection pour les chariots
de supermarché est né l'entreprise
s'appelle l'art balthier elle a imaginé
et conçu un dispositif à fontaine les
grès et plusieurs enseignes auboise
l'ont déjà adopté la société
industrielle a déjà reçu plus d'une
centaine de commandes en deux semaines
un intérêt suscité jusqu'à la corse vous
allez voir les gérants de l'entreprise
auboise espère surtout que son usage
perdurera au delà de cette crise
sanitaire à reportage de canal 32 dans
l'aube sur place regarder au delà de la
crise sanitaire du coc vide cette arche
de désinfection pourrait s'installer
durablement dans les lieux accueillant
du public
conçues et assemblées dans l'aube les
trois prototypes comme celui ci ont
immédiatement séduit tokyo - un peu
moins de risques suffit de pousser le
chariot en dessous ça c'est en fait tout
seul et franchement il n'ya pas de
contrainte et rémy
qui est simple d'utilisation on l'a vu
avec les gants et des masques
ça au moins c'est pas producteurs de
déchets la barre d'un caddie c'est ce
qui est porteur de différentes choses
c'est bien actuellement mais ça sera
forcément bien aussi par la fuite comme
aujourd'hui les plexiglas sur les quais
sans rites et c'est même dommage qu'il
ait fallu qui s est cette forte
problèmes sanitaires pour qu'on pense à
des choses comme ça concevoir des
solutions sur mesure pour les grandes
surfaces et boutiques c'est le coeur de
métier de l'entreprise larba laitiers
implantaire fontaine les grès sur les 25
millimètres carrés d'ateliers un espace
vient d'être ménagé pour la production
en série de cette arche ya encore une
semaine cet atelier n'existait pas vous
voyez il est en cours d'aménagement et
nous avons dédié une place de 1000 m²
pour ce nouveau produit pour qu'on
puisse se produire environ 10 machines à
la journée vous avez d'autres
alternatives
à l'heure actuelle où ce sont les
magasins qui passe les chariots dans des
salles de désinfection vous ne savez pas
entre temps ce qui s'est passé donc pour
nous c'était primordial que le client
soit acteur dans cette démarche de
sécurité un bidon de 20 litres permet la
désinfection de demi le chariot avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 20 millions
d'euros larba laitiers emploie 150
salariés et intervient partout en france
ici cette arche est perçu comme une
production supplémentaire et à long
terme
ça nous permet de garder le contact avec
nos clients et surtout de leur montrer
que nous sommes à leurs côtés pour
trouver des solutions sécuritaires ce
n'est pas seulement politique contre le
coc vide mais aussi pour lutter contre
toutes les bactéries qui nous embête
tout le temps à savoir la grippe et la
gastro entérite
voilà c'est il faut que ça devienne une
habitude pour le consommateur le coût de
cet équipement oscille entre 2600 et
3500 euros larba laitiers peut effectuer
sa mise en service
partout en france
nous partons à présent dans les vosges
dans ce grand vite et des territoires
le 18 mars dernier les archives
départementales des vosges ont pour la
première fois demandé directement aux
vosgiens et où vosgienne de raconter
leur vécu durant cette période de
confinement l'appel a été lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux sous le hashtag mémoire
de confinement il sera repris dans
d'autres régions de france et notamment
par les archives nationales du monde du
travail via vos jeux étaient sur place
pour nous raconter cette mémoire du
confinement regarder elles sont
légèrement sorties de leur rôle originel
les archives départementales des vosges
ont pour la première fois demandé
directement aux vosgiens 0 vosgienne de
raconter leur vécu durant la période de
confinement c'est au troisième jour le
18 mars que l'appel a été lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag mémoire
de confinement repris dans d'autres
régions de france
résultat une centaine de témoignages ont
été envoyés il retrace étapes par étapes
la crique sanitaire c'est des
témoignages que d'habitude on ne
collecte absolument jamais qu'on n'a pas
dans nos collections la première phase
un petit peu de découverte de peur
d'angoissé et puis ensuite le phénomène
qui s'installe dans la durée
puis ensuite à partir du déconfinement
déjà beaucoup de prudence
ça on le voit dans les messages les
vosges année les vosgiens qui nous ont
écrit au majoritairement sont plutôt
très prudent photos vidéos et votre
enregistrement sonore vont ainsi
constituer la mémoire de la vie
quotidienne d'une cinquantaine de
vosgiens ont participé des personnes qui
pour la plupart n'ont pas l'habitude
d'écrire est le thème qui revient
souvent c'est bien le rapport à la
nature les vosgiennes et les vosgiens
déjà sont contents de vivre sur leur
territoire parce qu'il leur permet de
sortir sans risque sanitaire
donc les gens peuvent profiter davantage
de la nature et puis aussi la nature se
rapproche il
ont des contacts plus fréquents avec les
animaux ce travail qui pourrait servir
aux sociologues et historiens les
archives du département des vosges
réfléchissent déjà aux différentes
manières de le présenter peut-être une
exposition peut-être une convention avec
le muséum du coc vide qui est une
institution numériques qui collectent
l'ensemble des témoignages de
confinement et on peut penser que la
mémoire des vosgiens sera pleinement
présente et exploiter au niveau mondial
grâce à son muséum du que dans les
vosges la collecte numérique peut être
complété par des témoignages sur papier
de quoi ravir ceux qui voudraient
prendre la plume et voir leurs écrits
être conservé pour l'éternité c'est son
côté inventoriées voilà c'est écolo et
cette entreprise française que vous
allez découvrir maintenant on est le
leader mondial
et si vous utilisiez de la peinture
issue de coquilles saint jacques
c'est le pari de i'll go pants
entreprises implantées en ille et
vilaine à verges sur seiche précisément
la peinture bio sourcés issus des
coquilles vides et plus résistante et
plus écologiques comme nous l'expliquent
que ce reportage des équipes de tvr à
rennes sur place algues au paint avait
un sur seiche avait sorti sa première
gamme de peintures bio sourcés à base
d'algues en 2016
dans quelques jours cette société va
mettre sur le marché une nouvelle
version pour les façades extérieures
grâce à l'ajout de poudre de coquilles
saint-jacques la coquille est
principalement composé de carbonate de
calcium et le carbonate de calcium une
fois que la coquille et bien micronisée
nous permet d'être produites dans nos
peintures et d'apporter une résistance
mécanique au film par rapport aux
intempéries aux agressions du temps et
du soleil et de la pluie après deux ans
de recherche et un dépôt de brevet helg
au peigne poursuit son aventure sur le
marché des peintures bio sourcés les
seuls dont les résines ne sont pas
fabriqués à partir de produits issus de
la pétrochimie et on voit qu'aujourd'hui
le consommateur est de plus en plus
friands et s'intéresse de plus en plus à
l'origine des produits et à la
composition chimique des produits algues
au paint est aujourd'hui leader français
des peintures bio
or c est fabriquée entièrement s'est
produit à vern sur seiche l'utilisation
de la saint jacques en circuit court va
aussi permettre de récupérer valoriser
une partie des coquilles vides qui
jusque là était tout simplement jetés
après récupération du mollusque par
l'industrie agroalimentaire
voilà les vacances approchent et pour
certains parents c'est le moment de se
préoccuper pour placer leurs enfants en
colonie de vacances en haute savoie
quelles sont les règles sanitaires qui
sont en vigueur dans les colonies de
vacances et comment se prépare l'accueil
des enfants sur place
notre partenaire de 8 mont blanc s'est
rendu à oignons dans le centre de
vacances dechavanne
c'est à reportage de clémence roald de
regarder fermée depuis le 15 mars
le centre de vacances les chavanat
oignons s'apprête à rouvrir ses portes
l'heure est aux derniers préparatifs
pour se conformer au protocole sanitaire
alors à cette porte en accède aux
chambres des enfants
là c'est un endroit où on allait pêcher
avec l'équipe parce que c'est à vous
passer de tous les enfants et tous les
adultes tous les pales contacter pour
nous on va essayer de les restreindre au
maximum cette porte qui est à l'origine
une porte coupe feu restera ouverte de
manière à éviter que tout le monde
prenne un peu nul tout le monde touche
l'organisation des chambres a été
repensé trois enfants en temps normal
ils ne seront plus que deux cet été dans
chaque chambre
par mesure de précaution un étage sera
entièrement dédiée en cas de suspicion
du coït 19 sur des champs qui seront
utilisés que si un cas de co vite se
présente au niveau des enfants
donc les enfants selon les zones et sur
sept étages ce centre fait partie des
colonies dites apprenantes un séjour
anglais et sciences y est proposé mais
pas question de parler d'école pendant
les vacances une colonie vacances c'est
avant tout des vacances et donc bien sûr
il y aura des séances d'anglais il y
aura des il y aura du jeu il y aura
différentes activités
il y aura peut-être même du camping cet
été en extérieur une activité drone sera
proposé aux enfants
malgré le protocole sanitaire il semble
que la colonie et trouver ses marques
on est parti sur un protocole très
restrictif qui s'est beaucoup allégés et
aujourd'hui on souffle un petit peu
parce que on avait peur que nos colonies
de vacances soit un petit peu trop sous
la forme de ce qui se passe à l'école ou
dans une prison c'est ce qu'on ne
voulait pas faire justement les premiers
enfants arriveront le 11 juillet sur le
site pour des vacances au grand air nous
partons en corse maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires où l'arrivée
des touristes est une nouvelle
rassurante pour le secteur de la
restauration
l'année dernière les structures des
plages de calvi avait été rasée en
raison de nouvelles réglementations
le nouveau cahier des charges a été
rempli et les petite paillote sont
facilement démontable maintenant et
surtout très écologique
comme vous allez le voir reportage les
pieds dans l'eau avec nos équipes sur
place de via télé pas aisée notre
vocation c'est de construire les maisons
d'habitation en ossature bois et dans ce
second temps d'aider conception
modulaire comme les paillotes qui vont
être placés sur la plage de calvi on a
eu un cahier des charges extrêmement
précis aux normes sanitaires les normes
environnementale que les normes incendie
les normes de sécurité et les normes
d'hygiène
les dimensions les auteurs et surtout la
donne esthétique vous avez donc était
aussi ralentie par rapport à cette crise
sanitaire
encore aujourd'hui on a des retards sur
les approvisionnements toutes les
lenteurs pour les demandes
j'espère que pour les je dirais la fin
de la première semaine de juillet on
sera en mesure d'ouvrir les
établissements et kelly les avantages
d'une paillote démontable comme celle ci
dans l'absolu une tempête arriverait en
quelques heures on est capable de
démonter la structure de la poser sur le
parking histoire de sécuriser le
matériel les assurances de sauver une
entreprise on s'attendait pas à ça en
passe et qu'on allait s'en sortir on
nous avait promis des choses on nous a
promis d'autres à la finalité on a dû
tout raser et on est parti à 0 au bout
de tant d'années on se retrouve à devoir
investir et vont partir sur des crédits
en falloir se relever mais on rentre
dans une année difficile avec le co vide
au milieu le retard pris par les
entreprises
on est un peu dans le dur là est ce que
vous prévoyez ans au cumul de la saison
est le recul de la saison on est
tributaire du temps donc
le nouveau cahier des charges comme vous
le voyez on n'a pas de structure fermée
ils nous ont interdit
des structures fermées des baies vitrées
des toitures fermes et donc pour
travailler après octobre 15 25 octobre
on est tributaire du vent il ya les
tramontane il ya le leem étudia le la
pluie on a le staff qui en attente tout
le monde est prêt on va bombarder pour
être prêt au plus tard le 10 15 juil si
tout se passe bien
autre région de france autre plage
direction la bretagne dans ce grand jt
des territoires avec les algues vertes
qui font une apparition tardive en baie
de saint brieuc
une expérimentation est donc lancée dans
les champs pour retenir leurs nutriments
qui est là zot ce grâce à la culture du
sarrasin vous allez le voir l'opération
est financée par l' agence de l'eau
loire bretagne et la région plus
d'explication chez l'un des agriculteurs
qui s'est lancé dans l'aventuré avec
mathilde de quéménès pour la chaîne
tébéo sur place le blé noir
permettra-t-il de limiter les marées
vertes cette culture a la particularité
de retenir la zot le nutriment t salle
dewerdt
quatre agriculteurs comme ce fromager
ont décidé de participer à une
expérimentation lancée par le pays de
saint-brieuc
il sait qu'un nouveau sa d'intérêt au
niveau ça donne très peu de
d'engrais pas de rejet du tout quasiment
dans les régulières cette
expérimentation intéresse aussi la
crêperie jarno implantée à lamballe elle
fabrique environ par an 500 milles
crêpes et galettes et souhaitent
s'approvisionner davantage en pleine
heure locale du premier c'est vraiment
d'intégrer cette cette expérimentation
pour montrer que le blé noir peut être
relocalisés mais oui nous on cherche
toujours à se fournir en matière
première locale dans la région le fait
pour le lait on le fait pour les yeux
plus on peut être proche de nous de
notre site de production mieux mieux
faire à ce jour trois cent dix
agriculteurs bretons se sont lancés dans
cette culture la production régionale
représente environ 20% du blé noir
consommée en france
on va dire que nous c'est une niche en
fait le blé noir en bretagne parce que
c'est quand même une culture qui est
assez compliquée même si elle est simple
on la sème on traite pas parce qu'on
garantisse en résidus de pesticides
elle a quand même des caractères
technique qui fait qu'on doit réussir
son semi et le point le plus important
après c'est la récolte verdict en
octobre lors de la récolte du blé noir
on sera alors si cette culture va
regagner le coeur des agriculteurs et
s'implanter de façon durable en pays de
saint brieuc
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans
l'actualité de ce grand jt des
territoires les cures thermales ont de
très nombreux adeptes
et après trois mois de fermeture la cure
saint-eloi vous allez le voir en moselle
accueille à nouveau des curistes pour
une réouverture optimale les employés
ont bien sûr suivi une formation de
prévention des risques liés aux qu'ovide
19 et un protocole sanitaires drastiques
réorganise tout le parcours de soins
elle est classée 8e de france la cure
thermale d'amnéville
elle espère voir revenir au plus vite
des curistes star portage de nos
confrères sur place devient mirabel
regarder confiné plus de trois mois la
cure thermale d'amnéville accueille de
nouveau des clients dès l'entrée le port
du masque est obligatoire et la
température des curistes contrôler sur
les onze mille mètres carrés de
l'établissement distanciation physique
et lavage des mains rythme les
déplacements des patients
des mesures sanitaires drastiques qui
ont un coût c'est de l'ordre de 100
mille cent mille euros quand même
maintenant vous me direz
la santé et la sécurité sanitaire n'ont
pas de prix donc on s'y prête de 2
volontiers dans un contexte financier
donc depuis quand même depuis le 14 mars
et 0 argent une situation aggravée par
la limitation du nombre de curistes et
des inquiétudes quant à leur retour
progressif dans l'établissement si bien
qu'à ce jour seuls un quart du personnel
a repris le travail
évidemment je serai la plus heureuse de
pouvoir faire rentrer tout le monde ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais c'est aussi
c'est dans une vision long terme si là
je fais rentrer tout le monde et qui a
personne évidemment dans une semaine on
ferme la porte
validée par l' agence régionale de santé
le nouveau parcours de soin de la cure
saint-eloi sens de rassurer les patients
privés des bienfaits de l'eau thermale
lors du confinement 80 curistes
souffrant d'affections rhumatologiques
ou des voies respiratoires se sont
précipités à amnéville et ce dès la
réouverture du site
j'en ai vu certains où il ya eu des
réveils de douleur qui étaient
importantes ils ont repris plus de
médicaments et était plus gênés ils ont
dû avoir recours certainement alors
rhumatologue où ils ont dû avoir eu des
infiltrations des choses comme ça on
plus suivi avec une augmentation de la
consommation médicale agréé par le
ministère de la santé
la cure thermale d'amnéville espère voir
revenir au plus vite à ses patients
l'année dernière elle avait accueilli et
soigné 16400 curistes nous continuons
notre tour de france de l'actualité dans
ce grand jt des territoires et nous
partons à présent dans les yvelines
la première phase du nettoyage de la
décharge sauvage de carrières sous
poissy a commencé en janvier dernier là
bas déjà 65 % des déchets ont été
nettoyés sur un espace de 3,7 hectares
cette opération est le résultat d'une
collaboration de l'état des différentes
collectivités territoriales et les trois
entreprises mandatées l'heure du premier
bilan un reportage de nicolas landry et
de patrick jacques de dixmude pour télé
78 la chaîne d ivry opération nettoyage
de la décharge sauvage de carrières sous
poissy une première phase lancée au mois
de janvier 2020 avec déjà 65 % de l'âme
à collecter spécialisée dans le
recyclage des matériaux l'entreprise
biche et à filiale du groupe colas est
chargé de trier et valoriser les déchets
notamment avec cette plateforme de tri
dans la plaine on va effectuer un
premier tri ce qui va nous permettre de
séparer les gros éléments
donc tout ce qui est là qui va pas
pouvoir être valorisée
la partie 30,80 donc c'est ce tapis là
sur lesquels on a installé un aspirateur
donc qu'il va aspirer les éléments
légers ensuite le reste passe sur le
tapis centrale tombe dans le band tri
donc à l'intérieur de la cabine y un
tapis principal quatre personnes qui
sont jaunes d'oeufs et deux de chaque
côté et qui vont trier le département a
sélectionné trois entreprises dans le
cadre de cette opération avec une
mission de surveillance et de pose de
clôture pour protéger cet espace un
investissement d'1 5 million d'euros de
l'état et du conseil départemental
vous avez là la démonstration que quand
la ja coordination et volonté de la part
des acteurs publics lorsqu'ils s'y
mettait les moyens barre il arrive à des
résultats spectaculaires
nous voulions voir le résultat du
travail collectif de dix heures acteurs
publics et privés je parle des
entreprises et acteurs publics ses
pensées départementale communauté
urbaine l'epamsa qui est un
établissement public de l'état je le
rappelle est l'état dans ce tout al
heure le président a prononcé le chiffre
de huit cent mille euros que nous devons
à l'engagement du préfet de région ile
de france
une deuxième phase de nettoyage va être
lancée au mois d'août 2020 objectif
dépolluer 75% de la plaine de déchets
d'ici à la fin de l'année un projet
d'aménagement d'un espace naturel
protégé en cours de réflexion est prévu
une fois la dépollution terminée voilà
nous partons dans la sarthe maintenant
avec une belle initiative que nous
souhaitions mettre en exergue dans ce
grand jt des territoires une initiative
solidaire due à l'association tarmac sur
place leurs idées bien c'est prendre en
location des logements appartenant à des
bailleurs propriétaires privés
l'association héberge ensuite les
personnes en situation précaire en
s'assurant de leur suivi
toutes les explications avec nos
confrères de lmtv sarthe
cette plaie
c'est le symbole d'un nouveau départ la
fin d'une période compliquée pour cette
jeune femme qui recherchait un
appartement depuis deux ans on va enfin
un fourgon enfin faut qu'on joue depuis
décembre dernier au mans une vingtaine
de personnes ont évité la rue grâce à
l'initiative solidaire un regard un
sourire un toit et l'association tarmac
c'est le cas de jonathan et sa compagne
qui ont passé cinq mois sans domicile
fixe une peut repartir sur de bonnes
bases et puis c'est un nouveau départ
c'est une libération pour une grosse
libération sinon je te remercie parce
que sans eux c'est le recul j'aurais pu
durer encore longtemps longtemps
allawi même si on pouvait payer un loyer
et cetera et cetera mais c'est compliqué
avec eux de trouver un appartement quand
on sort de la rue et trouver un
propriétaire qui veut bien nous faire
confiance
pour contourner cette difficulté
l'association tarmac fait tampon entre
le résident en est le propriétaire
l'association paye le loyer est
l'habitant rembourse l'association c'est
se dire mais est ce que nous aurons
toujours des loyers dans nos logements
puisque ça représente un investissement
ce type de démarche est en fait on a été
suffisamment sécurisé la confiance s'est
installée et donc on s'est dit allez on
saute le pas on y va au cours des
prochaines semaines d'autres logements
seront aussi mis à disposition d'ici le
15 juillet une dizaine de personnes
supplémentaires devraient ainsi
retrouver un logement
voilà c'est un défi un peu fou
maintenant nous vous présentons dans le
grand est et des territoires
un défi un peu fou qui prend place sur
le bassin d'arcachon en gironde où un
coureur a décidé d'en faire le tour
cela comprend donc aussi une traversée à
la nage une idée qui lui est venue en
plein confinement autant dire que depuis
l'accès à la plage a été rendue possible
et les entraînements se sont enchaînés
les équipes de tv7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest l'ont rencontré dans ses
derniers préparatifs
regardez ce reportage plus de 3 km de
nage et 75 km de course à pied c'est le
défi de taille que selon gregory
autrement dit boucler un tour complet du
bassin d'arcachon à droite avait pas mal
de temps que je me dis je ferais bien le
tour du bassin en courant parce que pour
moi le sport de prédilection que la
course à pied sauf qu'avec cette partie
pour faire le tour qui était la
traversée du bassin
parce que le bassin n'est pas fermée et
du coup traversée en navette ce n'était
pas dans l'esprit sportif que j'avais et
du coup pendant le confinement je suis
maintient finalement le ce serait bien
de le faire en nageant donc je vais
quand même vérifier par 6 jeux qu'ils
avaient la capacité de le faire
donc dès que le lait l'autorisation
d'accéder aux plages de manière
dynamique je me suis tentée sur la
partie natation avec le courant et
albert ça donnait le feu vert au projet
j'ai pu me lancer sur le défi un défi
personnel pour ce coach sportif plus
habitué au marathon et au trail avec en
toile de fond un objectif associatif
après forcément la volonté travailler
avec une association
je voulais travailler réclame de joie
malheureusement on n'a pas pu m
dispositif de collecte en place par
manque de temps je pouvais pas pousser
non plus le projet à cause de la saison
touristique qui arrivait mais ce sera à
qu'une partie remise grégory se donne
huit heures pour réaliser ce tour
complet du bassin en partant de la jetée
de bélisaire au cap ferret pour sa
sécurité en mer comme sur terre
il sera donc suivie sur l'ensemble de
son parcours
voilà cet été nous ferons le tour des
plages dans le grand jt des territoires
et nous partons maintenant sur la côte
d'azur où la saison des plages a enfin
redémarrer
regardez ce reportage de chip tv de
stephan appiah et de bruno alberti sur
place à nice la saison a enfin démarré
après le renouvellement de sa concession
l'équipe de la plage beau rivage
installé sur la promenade des anglais
nous parle des nouvelles installations
qui n'ont pas toujours été simples à
réaliser durant la période du
confinement la plage existe depuis 1950
moi je l'exploité depuis le 1er août
2005 on a eu le renouvellement ça
faisait un an et demi qu'on y travaille
est signée en février jean la période du
coc vide a énormément impact et
l'ouverture
ça a été une période je vais vous dire
c'est très simple incessants %
d'activité en moins je sais pas si on
peut connaître des crises comme ça on
avait un gros programme de rénovation
pour 2020 avec des installations très
importante au niveau au niveau de
l'intérieur vestiaires hammam salle de
sport donc on a réussi à quasiment faire
60% ou 70% de nos travaux et nous
gardons 30 % pour l'année prochaine avec
une très belle surprise d'année
prochaine qui sera un espace tendance
avec piscine et bars extérieurs qui sera
absolument magnifique
on a transformé le négatif en positif
aujourd'hui on est ouvert on a une
superbe plage
le nouveau chef de la plage alexandre
libera nous a présenté sa nouvelle carte
là le fil conducteur était la
méditerranée forcément on est sur une
plage donc le poisson l'huile d'olive
les agrumes
c'est ce qui me corresponde mieux dans
ma cuisine on sert toute la journée on a
le restaurant ou à servir jusqu'à 16
heures un autre ailleurs donc comme
jusqu'à 200 250 couverts
mozilla la partie lounge sur les matelas
de notre loup convaincu avec une flamme
avec un chalumeau ou directement sur la
peau on a admis ce côté un peu
barbecue le pount la tentacule entière
qui est cuit en basse température
longuement dans un bouillon
qui est vraiment exquise farouchement un
peu le poisson plus en ceviche entarter
est toujours sept notes d'agrumes qu'on
va on va ajouter l'atmosphère de cette
plage s'inscrit dans un esprit dolce
vita et le thème c'est vraiment c'est
l'esprit niçois quoi c'est la douceur de
vivre donc j'évite à l'accueil la
douceur de vivre le plaisir
l'entretien toute cette clientèle qui
est très attaché à la plage on a eu des
beaux témoignages
les gens avaient hâte de revenir et nous
l'ont prouvé dès l'ouverture
le directeur général entre nadia a
toujours essayé d'innover en préservant
l'histoire riche de ce lieu j'ai essayé
j'espère avoir réussi en partie à
préserver son historique en la mettant
dans la modernité en même temps on a
engagé un grand chef
on monte en gamme chaque année c'est ça
ment c'est ça mon but
j'aime bien quand je me retourne d'une
année sur l'autre média est encore plus
beau que l'année dernière parce que je
considère que je me suis là que pour un
petit moment par rapport à l'histoire du
gorille a changé wrap longtemps que moi
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
ou sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve bien sûr pour une
nouvelle édition au revoir à tous et bon
courage
[Musique]